hello welcome back to the game spots age
right here at e3 2015 i'm joined by span
and firing from Larian studios thank you
for coming all the way from belgium and
to show us off the console version of a
game that one actually at won gamespot's
pc game of the year in 2014 that's
correct affinity original sin and now
coming to the PlayStation 4 yeah an xbox
one off an xbox one as well is showing
the ps4 version here so we've got a we
better running here on the stage so what
is this what is enhanced edition is it
just e is this a port of the pc version
are you adding stuff oh it's much more
than that it's a we actually consider it
like a completely different game oh wow
because we've added so much stuff to it
it's had full voice recordings we revamp
the entire skill system every single
skill which was in there which was a
little bit useless was replaced by
another skill we've added a lot of extra
quest enhanced content we've changed the
entire ending of the game oh well we
will really did a lot of things on top
of it excellent let's see it in action
and I guess the best way of showing is
to actually see it happening and so
whereabouts are we now how long into the
game is this big burn how long into the
game is this there are about 15 hours in
the game and we're in place called
silver glen and so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to show off the
controls by doing some elemental
interactions so I just cost I midnight
oil on the fire surface which calls it
to extent and connect with the poison
surface and that basically made it yeah
well explode everything essentially now
I'm dowsing that fire now I select a
lining skill that's making like doesn't
making the electrify the water and if I
do that again I'm going to freeze the
entire thing that's just like the base
elemental interactions that you have so
you have your whole bar at the bottom
you can toggle it you can reconfigure it
whenever you want and then obviously if
I fall on the ice guys I will fall on my
on your ass as such a great element of
the game was was was how those different
sort of environmental mechanics say that
the puzzle solving I'm actually how you
use them in combat as well yeah so
that's that's the next player thing
we're going to look at I'll head into
combat so you can see how that works and
the divinity series has been around for
a long time
original sin I'm guessing was the most
successful of any of the divinity game
by far yeah so it did really well last
year and we were really happy with
results so I entered combat here is the
combats turn-based so I'm Scarlett my
fire mage is first in line so we have a
bunch of elemental flowers here so evil
smelling flowers and then a bunch of
earth elementals so if i look at the
earth elementals i can easily examine
what their stats are and i see that i
have a vulnerability to air so i have to
have my lightning spell with me so i'm
going to see if I can cast that one it's
just in rage I'm going to do that and my
stunt failed unfortunate but it did
indeed do edge so at the bottom of the
bar you see that i have my action points
so if i want to move it's going to cost
me action points right now I only have
one extra point so I'm going to keep it
and it's going to carry over into the
next turn let's see what the end meet us
so this guy is hasting himself we
actually revamped every single encounter
in the game we had a lot of extra AI not
really we added a new mode of gameplay
with skull tactician and which the AI is
actually based on all the things we saw
people do and so it knows all the
counters so really interesting yeah so
what was the impetus for making all
these additions to the game are you
trying to make a new type of game for
fans of original sin or you are you
trying to make a sort of the purest
version of original said the best
version I think it's a more flattered
there were a number of things that we
were unhappy about I mean the game was
already pretty good but there were a lot
of areas where we could improve it and
given it was so successful and we were
bringing to console I started with the
console port and it says you know what
we'll just go for the entire thing yeah
and we overdid it honestly but where
yeah we really overdid yeah I'm costing
a new master skill here which is called
rain of arrows so master skills are also
a new thing so as you had a deeper into
the game you're going to be able to
learn a whole bunch of new skills at end
the past you couldn't access actually so
these are grenades that's all so new I'm
going to fast-track my rope here and
to make him go into the back step area
of this earth elemental so that's also
something new so he has extra action
points as a result of the fast track if
you look at him you'll see that he now
has dual wielding the loot system has
also been completely interchanged so if
i go to my two daggers here they're
legendary daggers so that's also new
that's been added as well as the fact of
course that i can do my that i can do my
back step on this guy yes I'm gonna up
sorry i'ma split there so let me go in
there and select the guy and do a
backstab damage nice that's guaranteed
critical damage alright so I'm going to
carry over into my next turn see these
flowers are attacking him but he's
immune to poison so that's also a neat
thing to have and I'm planning actually
to to kill the soul and one big move
with a master skill which is meteor
shower which my fire mage has and that's
this one over here so if i'm going to
call this on them get them all together
to do a lot of boom there we go so
master skills require all of action
points and they only become available
once you invested a lot in certain
abilities but once you have them you can
do a lot of damage unfortunately the
enemy also has that so they are going to
do well eventually use all those things
against you so then you'll have to find
counters against that and considering
you've added so much to this and is this
coming out on pc at all yes it is as
well everybody who bought the game on
steam or on GOG is going to get game for
free actually you can really pretty
separate real there in their Steam
library that's incredible how do you how
do you justify that yourself is this
something like giving back to the fans
or that's it I mean original sin
definitely has allowed us to do a lot
more in the game and as a result of that
we could make this thing and so we said
okay well we're just going to give it
for free because they already paid for
original sin yeah so we're making the
enhanced edition on sedition is aimed
also at the console audience so they
haven't been able to try this out this
is the first time that the game like
this actually has been made for a
console we've tried to find something
and I think like in the entire history
of console Dom there's nothing like this
yes actually one which has the feature
which I'm about to show you right now so
if firing if you can join in yeah sure
i'll just create he's going to join me
you can play the game on console online
multiplayer so you can play against one
and out or with one another and what we
did now here is firing joined in and so
he took control of Roderick which is one
of the characters excellent and we are
now in cop mode split screen and get you
can drop in drop out runs really
anything you want I'm basically a full
fledge earlier like just a singer I'm so
impressed by the the interface you've
done as well because obviously you guys
are what I consider you of like a very
like PC centric developing but a lot
more sort of lines of resolution people
sit closer to the screen like making
classic style or bee gees there's so
much interface going on what was it like
for you trying to make this work
properly with like a controller and also
making it you know make it so it's
visible especially when you split the
screen down and double up everything it
was a lot of work I mean we we started
working tonight actually when the
original sin came out and we spent a
year on it with like at that time the
entire studio so there's doing the
changes with also actually implementing
the split-screen making it run in full
HD on both xbox one and ps4 so that was
that was quite some effort so let me
head into a silver glen here and show
you a little bit more of what we can do
so i'm in front of the house of a guy
here who is holding a secret and this is
a village and my my mission here is to
figure out where his secret hideout is
he's ahead of an immaculate cold and so
there are several ways that I can do
this and I'll but first maybe we should
show
II let me stare like Scarlett here and
talk to Roderick so this is our
cooperative dialogue system we can chat
with each other now but now it's much
cooler because we're sitting next to one
another yeah right that was actually
always the vision of the game that you
were going to be able to do that so I am
now asking him like where the hell were
you during the fight so and well
whoop-de-doo it's like you to come back
up yeah exactly yeah the thing about
this is also we voice recorded every
single dialogue in the game wow we
started a recording and the beginning of
January and so we finished actually last
week so there's a there's a there's all
the voice in their 88,000 lunch and some
fantastic quests like that the stories
and the quest do you find in the village
original sin is so many that sort of the
last you remember and have you have you
changed any of those I'm guessing about
it a lot when you actually in the
original game you had these generic
dialogues that have all been removed
replaced by unique dialogue Wow with a
lot of extra characterization all of the
character so that they're more
interesting that you have for more
immersion for them we added stuff to
quest we make new quest as i said we
change the entire ending also so that's
that's really reward that's really
rewarding when you get there yeah we
have gave it back a companions extra
backgrounds the puzzles are all
different if you play a technician mode
you'll discover that you have completely
set of different puzzles that's awesome
hello there's a lot in here I feel
terrible for even saying that this is a
port I think at the start of this
interview here you guys it's not a war
it's amazing i am i writing say it's
been so long they're like my memory is
sort of at betraying me but was divinity
original sin originally a kickstarter
game as well there's like one of the
earlier ones yeah we were one of an we
kick started in april 2013 yeah so
that's some time ago already do you
think you'd go down that route again has
that been a of like a you guys have had
a series that's been around for a long
time the affinity series but was a
backup 2002 or something yeah yeahs o
divinity one or divine divinity as i was
called it was released in 2002 and so
been around for what what is that 13
years or so yeah we're raging ourselves
here and for you guys using Kickstarter
it's not something you'll do again like
even if you don't require the money to
do it maybe you do maybe don't that sort
of interaction with your fans was that
worthwhile well that definitely I mean
so we had to Kickstarter and then we had
the early access right and those to
shape the game tremendously because we
had an enormous amount of feedback from
them so I think that will probably be
interested in doing something like that
but we still have to have a lot of work
to do to finish this one and we're
working on the next one so stay tuned
for that awesome and when will we be
able to play the enhanced edition of
divinity original soon it's good to come
out this fall so we are hoping for
October but we still have some work on
it there's about 5,000 bucks to crush no
it's not ready then it'll be a little
bit later but it's coming it's going to
come I could sit here and watch you guys
play all day do you have any more of
this quest you can show us yeah sure
yeah that's good oh yeah a little though
so this is how you sneak right I turn
myself into a bush if I get seen by a
line of sight come on here you see back
come here will you well it's supposed to
see me but he's short-sighted cat
alright nevermind i'm going to go inside
here so i'm going to show you one of the
ways that i can access something which
is behind a very long quest and that is
actually by using the mechanics of the
game but what i'm going to do to do that
is i'm going to give control of the game
too far so because i can switch control
over the character out for wrong choice
so if I so I can say for instance okay
you can control ball graph which is my
rogue so and I'm going to go off with my
characters to do something else over
there so if you can do the alright so
basically as friend said we're source
hunters and we're in this little village
to actually infiltrate in this cult
called the immaculate and you can do
that through the design way which is
talking to this character or we can use
the systemics as van mentioned in this
case we got a lock hatch here which
Lloyd the high priest is very protective
about so he really doesn't want me
touching this but I know he's a high
priest and he's got to have access to
sacred stone their base of operations so
I'm guessing that underneath this hatch
there is a portal that he uses to get
there so we're going to try to do is
we're going to become you know we're
going to go in sneak mode and see we can
actually a pickpocket this guy
apparently I'm a barrel now but the
moment I move into anybody's line of
sight I'll get caught now what these you
know QA guys discovered was if you
actually make yourself invisible and
then go into sneak mode the systemics of
the game will make sure that characters
don't see you oh my so then I can
actually move behind them pickpocket him
which opens his pocket I can take the
keys that we want also there you much
don't take too much yeah also the amulet
because we really need the amulet but
you know pickpocketing is based on
weight and value if you pick up really
heavy stuff they'll notice immediately
that they're being pickpocketed so I'll
go out of my sneak mode and we're in his
little hideout here and as expected
there's a waypoint that leads us to near
the village and we also got all this
stuff we can loot another thing was you
know we're converting a pc game you know
the controls of the pc game we're
conveying it to the console and the
biggest problem is that on the pc you
could point and click stuff but you
can't really do that on the console so
we had separately you know several ways
of actually selecting stuff like if you
look at things and you use your shoulder
buttons you can actually cycle through
them I'll cool you can click your left
thumbstick to activate a cruiser mode
that you can accurately move over stuff
and do things with but we also have our
area search mode if you hold expressed
anything that falls in the diameter
actually gets put in the list and you
can interact with it and basically you
can really do anything you want with it
you can even read notes from this list
so we we've really tried our best to
involve these separate ways of gameplay
so that people can play this game as
comfortably as they can over a span of a
few hours because it's it saves so much
time the thing is it's a big game and if
you want to play it any way you want you
should be able to do that so it's
important to note also that we didn't
remove anything that was there in bc
verso the same amount of deficit yeah
basically what everybody was wondering
about can you actually
good as a controller and so based on
what we've seen here people playing it
looks like it's really going a it takes
them one to two minutes and then they're
in Xcode as Federer firing thank you so
much for coming on the gamespot stage
and showing his divinity have a best of
luck and finishing this version I can't
wait to see it more and I can't wait to
play through it again on my playstation
4 extravagance and that's excellent and
that's at the end of game spots day 2
right here at e3 2015 we got a bumper a
day coming up tomorrow though III is not
quite a company there's only day two it
feels like we've been here for about
five or six days at this stage tell me
the place I started on Sunday exactly
and tomorrow we got a bunch of cool
stuff on parmer luck he's gonna be on
and mostly talking about oculus I match
him Gears of Ultimate Edition street
fighter 5 and a bunch more games so make
sure you stay tuned to gamespot com
thank you so much for watching on
gamespot on youtubes III hub and of
course on hitbox thank you so much
everyone in the production crew for
setting up today's show making a run oh
so smooth like butter and we'll be back
tomorrow take care